لقد مروا عبر وادي
ظل الموت
في الغالب ولكن ليس كلهم ​​خرجوا من
الوادي
أحياء لكنهم لم يصابوا بأذى
على امتداد الطريق هذا المطل على
معارك باهاموت وسوليداد ، إنه
آمن بما يكفي لتسليم الجرحى
إلى المسعفين
المنتشرين على طول الطريق على
نقالة ملطخة بالدماء وسترة واقية من الرصاص ملطخة بالدماء ،
هذه القوات تعود لتوها من الجبهة ، حيث
قال المقاتلون إنهم كانوا يتجهون إلى الوراء.
القتال الذي رأوه كان شديدًا ،
كان هناك جنود نظاميون يقول هذا
الجندي وأمامهم فقط قابلوا
المدانين وهجمات على المخدرات بدون
دروع بدون خوذات بالنسبة لهم الحياة
ليس لها قيمة
في The Killing Fields ،
يستمر القصف دون توقف للمسعفين ولا
راحة
في بعض الأحيان ، لا تمنحنا قذائف الهاون أي
مساحة للتنفس يخبرني مسعف الأناضول أن
لدينا العديد من الإصابات
عندما يأتي القناصون الجرحى من الجنود القتلى ثم هناك
العديد من القتلى
من
السيارات المدرعة.